voilà pour la situation en sous dans en
Ukraine à présent nouvelle salle de
bombardements russes à travers le pays
plusieurs missiles ont frappé l'Ukraine
cette nuit c'était le cas qui est flat
capitale mais aussi à ni pro ou encore à
rerson reverson au moins une personne
est morte regain d'intensité des
opérations russes alors que l'Ukraine
annonce se préparait une grande
offensive contre-offensive pour en
apprendre plus on va retrouver en direct
à notre correspondant en Ukraine
Gulliver crack bonjour Gulliver Gulliver
les Russes on le sait ont pris
l'habitude de frapper les
infrastructures énergétiques
ukrainiennes ça c'était par le passé
est-ce que c'est le cas de ces nouvelles
frappes
visiblement on a un petit problème de
son avec notre correspondant
gulliverkrack on va retrouver dans
quelques minutes on va tout de suite
continuer à évoquer la situation en
Ukraine avec notre chroniqueur
international en plateau Gautier
ribbinsky bonjour Gauthier bonjour
Antoine Gautier je le disais les
Ukrainiens affirme depuis plusieurs
semaines vouloir se lancer dans une
grande contre-offensive massive pourquoi
pourquoi cette communication Gauthier
oui parce que d'ordinaire vous
conviendrait avec moi que avertir
l'adversaire ou l'ennemi de la tenue
d'une contre-offensive lorsqu'on a dit
évidemment qu'il fallait attendre le
début du printemps qu'il fallait
attendre ce dégel et puis ensuite la
période dite de raspoutit ça qui est une
période au cours de laquelle la boue est
tellement vous allez dire développer
notamment dans les campagnes
qu'elle fixe ou empêche oblitère toute
tentative d'offensive notamment avec des
blindés mais une fois qu'on sait ça le
fait que
l'Ukraine a joué dans sa communication
de cette perspective que les Occidentaux
également en parlent d'une manière très
détachée c'est ça qui est étrange
d'abord parce que c'est pas quelque
chose dont on peut rire mais en plus de
ça pourquoi laisser le temps non
seulement le temps Horus éventuellement
de ce requinquer mais en plus en leur
disant bon en gros ça sera vers fin
avril début mai voir mimer bon il y a
une raison à cela la raison c'est que
dans ce contexte là la Russie qui
d'habitude est habituée précisément par
Vladimir Poutine à maîtriser le
calendrier et à l'imposer aux autres là
c'est l'inverse c'est l'ukrain qui dit
bah voilà on va faire ça comme si
d'ailleurs la Russie devait opposer
aucune résistance ce qui n'est pas gagné
mais il y a cette cette ce côté oui
effet d'annonce et affichage et essayer
de profiter de cette affichage en disant
voilà vous voyez bien que cette
offensive va avoir lieu
nous avons le matériel d'ailleurs l'OTAN
dit
l'Ukraine à tout ce qu'il faut et il va
falloir justement qu'elle s'en sorte
avec ça sauf qu'il y a pas les avions ça
c'est un une autre paire de manches mais
il va falloir qu'elle prouve ce qu'il en
est et pour l'Ukraine c'est aussi un
rendez-vous important parce que si cette
conte offensive n'apportait pas les
succès escomptés ça serait très
compliqué par la suite de se réorganiser
immédiatement donc vous voyez il y a il
y a cette effet de calendrier qui
consiste à le maîtriser et à dire aux
Russes c'est nous qui maîtrisons la
chose et pas vous ce qui est aussi une
forme de victoire même si elle est pas
sur le terrain militaire c'est une
victoire psychologique qui est très
forte j'ajoute aussi le fait que vous
avez des mouvements de désertion au sein
de l'armée russe avec certains avocats
qui essayent de protéger au nom d'un
droit qui a été oublié en Russie mais
qui essaye de protéger ses soldats là et
là aussi c'est peut-être de la part des
Ukrainiens se dire si on imprime cette
peur ou Solidaris quand déserté ça peut
être une occasion de le faire pour eux
vous évoquez les Russes justement en
Gauthier ils ont poursuivi leur
stratégie de bombardement massif à
travers à travers le pays mais il faut
dire également qu'il y a une relative à
calmer dans les combats un certain
moment est-ce que d'une certaine manière
les Russes eux en ont profité vous
l'évoquez pour ce requinquer d'une
certaine manière alors vous savez les
problèmes de l'armée russe ils sont pas
conjonctuels ils sont ils sont
structurés vous ce que l'on sait qui est
presque une un lieu commun c'est les
problèmes techniques et
d'approvisionnement en pièces je vous
donne cet exemple parce que quand un
char ou un blindé russe a une pièce
défectueuse normalement on en commandit
mais elle arrive surtout quand il s'agit
de l'armée rapidement bah là c'est pas
le cas et que font les soldats qui sont
en charge de l'entretien et de la
maintenance de ces engins bah c'est
aller détacher c'est prendre une pièce
détachée dans un autre engin pour que
l'autre soit réparé et de ce fait là il
y a un gaspillage énorme vous avez
quantité de blindé russe qui sont
inutilisables non pas parce que
le matériau et défectueux non pas parce
que la conception est mauvaise mais
parce que tout simplement il faut faire
du ce qu'on appelle du cannibalisme et
ça c'est un problème structurel ce qui
est structurel aussi on le voit bien
dans l'armée russe c'est le fait que
la plupart des soldats sont les
conscrits qu'ils ont été soumis à des
formes de violence au sein de leur
caserne qu'on ne les a pas informés de
ce qu'ils allaient faire en Ukraine et
ça c'est quand même un monde pour
Poutine c'est la preuve de son imposture
il dit le peuple russe est avec moi pour
reconquérir au fond de notre grandeur
sauf que ceux qui sont au premier loge
ne savent pas pourquoi ils sont là et
enfin parce que pour ces soldats il
s'agit si vous voulez de commettre un
certain nombre d'aptes je ne parle pas
forcément des crimes de guerre mais qui
sont si vous voulez en contradiction
avec la théorie générale des frères
ukrainiens et que finalement il se
demande pourquoi ils sont là donc je ne
dis pas que tout ça va jouer
d'une manière absolument certaine en
faveur des Ukrainiens mais ça n'est pas
des conditions si vous voulez que
l'armée russe a pu dans l'humérus a pu
tirer parti pour ce requinquer pour se
refaire une santé finalement en si peu
de temps et c'est là que si vous voulez
intervient régulièrement les menaces de
Poutine d'utilisation du fenucléaire
parce que il sait que regarder darkmouth
pour conclure par contre qui dans ton a
dit à plusieurs reprises que les Russes
l'avaient conquise et c'est toujours pas
le cas et du coup vous avez même pris
gogé une de Wagner qui dit on risque un
désastre ça sans doute pas faux même si
lui essaye de se profiler comme on dit à
titre personnel merci beaucoup Gauthier
pour cette analyse Gautier reviens ski
notre chroniqueur international pour
France 24